This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Look up at the sky in most places in the world and you will see flocks of birds. Look carefully and you'll see these flocks are usually made up of the same kind of birds. Pigeons flap around with other pigeons, crows with crows, starlings congregate with well,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在世界上的大多数地方抬头望向天空，你都会看到成群的鸟儿。仔细观察，你会发现这些鸟群通常由同一种鸟组成。鸽子和鸽子一起拍打翅膀，乌鸦和乌鸦在一起，椋鸟则聚集在一起，嗯，
lots and lots of other starlings. Somewhere along the way, someone coined a memorable phrase, birds of a feather flocked together. Sociologists have noticed that this phenomenon is not restricted to birds. Humans tend to do the same thing, Except because we are complex creatures, the things that draw us together are not just physical similarities, but cultural constructions, such as social class, shared interests, and common cuisines. We think nothing of the fact that music lovers hang out with other music lovers, or that book readers congregate in book clubs, and that gardeners form their own societies. The internet has made it possible for people with all manner of niche interests
和许许多多其他的椋鸟在一起。不知从什么时候起，有人创造了一个令人难忘的短语：物以类聚，人以群分。社会学家注意到，这种现象并不仅限于鸟类。人类也倾向于做同样的事情，只是因为我们是复杂的生物，吸引我们走到一起的不仅仅是身体上的相似性，还有文化建构，比如社会阶层、共同的兴趣和共同的饮食习惯。我们认为音乐爱好者和音乐爱好者混在一起，或者读书爱好者聚集在读书俱乐部，园艺爱好者组成他们自己的协会，这些都是理所当然的事。互联网使得各种各样有小众兴趣的人
to discover others who are exactly like them. When we do think about this at all, we usually say it's a wonderful thing. Well, it is and it isn't. This week on Hidden Brain, the unintended consequences of enjoying the company of others who are just like us. The next time you attend a wedding, take a close look at the couples around you. The couple getting married, sure, but all the other couples too. How many couples do you think have both members vote for the same political party, or belong to the same race, or speak the same language?
能够发现和他们完全一样的人。当我们思考这个问题时，我们通常会说这是一件美妙的事情。嗯，它既是，也不是。本周在《隐藏的大脑》中，我们将探讨享受与我们相似的人为伴所带来的意想不到的后果。下次你参加婚礼时，仔细看看你周围的夫妇。当然是那对正在结婚的夫妇，但也要看看其他所有的夫妇。你认为有多少对夫妇双方都投票给同一个政党，或者属于同一个种族，或者说同一种语言？
The answer is obvious. Most people married to each other have similar backgrounds. They are usually of the same race or ethnicity. They might even have attended the same schools or work in similar professions. This hasn't always been the case. The old trope on television was the business executive or law firm partner invariably a man who ran off with the secretary. The new reality is that law firm partners tend to marry other
答案显而易见。大多数结婚的人都有相似的背景。他们通常属于同一个种族或族裔。他们甚至可能上过同一所学校，或者从事相似的职业。情况并非总是如此。电视上的老套路是企业高管或律师事务所合伙人——通常是一个男人——与秘书私奔。新的现实是，律师事务所的合伙人倾向于与其他
highly paid lawyers. Doctors get hitched to other medical professionals, especially in well-to-do communities, it's vanishingly rare for people to marry others from starkly different backgrounds. Matches that span significant educational divides, where one person has gone to say graduate school, while the other hasn't finished high school, are extremely rare. At Stanford University, Luigi Pistaferi studies the consequences of such matching. He uses the usual tools of the economist,
高薪律师结婚。医生与医疗专业人士结合，特别是在富裕社区，人们与背景截然不同的人结婚的情况极其罕见。跨越巨大教育鸿沟的结合——比如一个人读了研究生，而另一个人连高中都没读完——是非常罕见的。在斯坦福大学，路易吉·皮斯塔费里研究了这种匹配的后果。他使用了经济学家的常用工具，
models, math, and data. But besides being an economist, Luigi is also a Jane Austen fan. The most important novel of Jane Austen, Pride and Prejudice, is kind of centered around the fact that the Bennett family wants to have all the daughters been married to people from hopefully higher social classes. You might remember the story. It centers around one of the Bennett daughters, Elizabeth, and her unlikely relationship
模型、数学和数据。但除了是一名经济学家，路易吉还是简·奥斯汀的粉丝。简·奥斯汀最重要的小说《傲慢与偏见》在某种程度上围绕着这样一个事实：班内特一家希望所有的女儿都能嫁给社会阶层更高的人。你可能还记得这个故事。它以班内特家的一个女儿伊丽莎白为中心，讲述了她与
with Mr. Darcy, a very wealthy bachelor. His name is Darcy, and he has a mighty fortune at a greater state in Derbyshire. Their romance is unlikely, because Elizabeth is supposed to be well beneath Mr. Darcy's social class. When the seemingly mismatched lovers finally overcome many hurdles and get together, we are left with a treetly conclusion that love conquers all. I have been selfish being all my life. As a child I was given good principles, but I was left to follow them in pride and conceit.
达西先生——一位非常富有的单身汉——之间那段不太可能的恋情。他叫达西，在德比郡拥有巨大的财富和庄园。他们的恋情是不太可能的，因为伊丽莎白被认为远低于达西先生的社会阶层。当这对看似不般配的恋人最终克服了重重障碍走到一起时，我们留下了一个“爱能征服一切”的甜蜜结论。我一生都很自私。小时候，我被教导了良好的原则，但我却任由自己在骄傲和自负中遵循它们。
Such I might still have been with you. You know, it's lovely, it still is. As a Jane Austen fan, Luigi loved the story, but as an economist, he doesn't buy the plot. You know, it's the kind of the comical aspect of it that is interesting. Together with the fact that it seems in the, you know, from watching the movies that the bandits are actually a lower social class, well, in fact, they were probably themselves in the top 10% of the time, you know, the three or four girls, I remember how many sisters there were, they were illiterate and, you know, they could have
如果我当时和你在一起，我可能还是那样。你知道，这很可爱，现在依然如此。作为简·奥斯汀的粉丝，路易吉喜欢这个故事，但作为一名经济学家，他不买账。你知道，这其中滑稽的一面很有趣。再加上从电影中看，班内特一家似乎是较低的社会阶层，而事实上，他们当时可能处于社会前10%，你知道，那三四个女孩，我不记得有多少个姐妹了，她们受过教育，而且，你知道，她们家里可以有
servants in their house, already tells you that, you know, the Bennett family actually is not poor, but given their norms and amount of wealth inequality, there was at that time, it looks as if the kind of lower ranks of the society, while in fact they were pretty high up. Luigi says that if you think about pride and prejudice through the lens of an economist, in fact, if you think of love and marriage through the lens of an economist, you start to see things differently. You start to see lots and lots of what sociologists call homophily. Birds of a feather flocking together.
仆人，这已经告诉你，你知道，班内特一家其实并不穷，但考虑到当时的规范和财富不平等的程度，看起来他们像是社会底层，而实际上他们地位相当高。路易吉说，如果你通过经济学家的视角来看《傲慢与偏见》，事实上，如果你通过经济学家的视角来看待爱情和婚姻，你就会开始以不同的方式看待事物。你会开始看到社会学家所说的“同质性”。物以类聚，人以群分。
We economists tend to think in terms of markets, so here I'm referring to what we call the marriage market. So the marriage market homophily means someone marrying someone similar to themselves. So that could be cast in terms of wealth. I can be cast in terms of levels of education. It can be cast in terms of income. People from relatively high social classes try to marry someone from the very top of the distribution of social classes.
我们经济学家倾向于从市场的角度思考，所以我这里指的是我们所说的“婚姻市场”。因此，婚姻市场的同质性意味着一个人与和自己相似的人结婚。这可以从财富的角度来衡量，可以从教育水平的角度来衡量，也可以从收入的角度来衡量。来自相对较高社会阶层的人试图与来自社会阶层分布最顶端的人结婚。
That would be Mr. Darcy, for example, in the novel. So the research in economics is a form of homophily we call it a sartini mating. A sort of mating is what you see when doctors pair up with other doctors. Or lawyers marry other lawyers. It goes back to that idea we discussed that most people tend to choose partners who are similar to themselves, in background, in education, in wealth. Several powerful forces drive a sort of mating.
例如，在小说中，那就是达西先生。因此，经济学中的研究是一种我们称之为“选型交配”的同质性。当你看到医生与医生配对，或者律师与律师结婚时，你看到的就是选型交配。这回到了我们讨论过的那个观点，即大多数人倾向于选择在背景、教育、财富方面与自己相似的伴侣。几种强大的力量推动了选型交配。
Think about how and where people tend to meet romantic partners. On dating apps, you can filter potential matches based on education, professional background, age, and physical appearance. And the places where people are most likely to meet potential partners in real life, those tend to be school and work, situations where you are overwhelmingly likely to find others with similar interests and educational backgrounds. There are, you know, frictions, what we call frictions, costs of actually exploring the universe of potential mates that you can have. And so, you know, given that you don't have a lot of time to do this, you tend to marry people you encounter or you meet with in places where you spend most of your time. So it could be the workplace, it could be the place where you went to college and
想想人们倾向于在哪里以及如何结识浪漫伴侣。在约会软件上，你可以根据教育程度、职业背景、年龄和外貌来筛选潜在的匹配对象。而在现实生活中人们最有可能结识潜在伴侣的地方，往往是学校和工作场所，在这些地方，你极有可能找到与你有相似兴趣和教育背景的人。你知道，存在摩擦，我们称之为“摩擦”，即探索你可能拥有的潜在伴侣世界的成本。所以，你知道，鉴于你没有太多时间做这件事，你倾向于与你在花费大部分时间的地方遇到的人结婚。所以这可能是工作场所，可能是你上大学的地方，并且
indeed we observe a lot of the matches actually occurring happening through these two channels. There's a lot of people who end up meeting the person they marry, work or in college. This is a very common occurrence. On a recent visit to Chicago, I heard that 50% of University of Chicago undergrads end up marrying someone else from the same school. Now, that number seems improbably high, but the fact remains, homophily is a real thing in the marriage market. What striking Luigi says is how movies and popular culture celebrate a world that is very different than reality. He cites a famous movie from 1990.
事实上，我们观察到很多匹配确实是通过这两个渠道发生的。有很多人最终与他们在工作或大学里遇到的人结婚。这是一种非常普遍的现象。最近在芝加哥访问时，我听说50%的芝加哥大学本科生最终与同一所学校的其他人结婚。现在，这个数字看起来高得不可思议，但事实仍然是，同质性在婚姻市场中是真实存在的。路易吉说，令人震惊的是，电影和流行文化如何颂扬一个与现实截然不同的世界。他引用了1990年的一部著名电影。
The modern scene in the real story is, you know, kind of pretty woman. Add the moi richa gear and the, and junior Roberts. Hey sugar, you looking for a date? No, I want to find Beverly Hills. Can I give you directions? Sure. For five bucks. Ridiculous.
现实故事中的现代场景是，你知道，有点像《风月俏佳人》。加上理查·基尔和朱莉娅·罗伯茨。嘿，甜心，你在找约会对象吗？不，我想找比佛利山庄。我能给你指路吗？当然。五块钱。荒谬。
Crashes from up to ten. All right, okay. If all right, you win, I lose. Ah, so the story of a very wealthy man meeting almost randomly, the very poor girl, and then eventually, essentially marrying, I think, that's what the movie suggested. So that is an example that I use to show that the probability of that happening in the data is extremely low, although it's not zero.
从十块钱降下来。好吧，好吧。如果好吧，你赢了，我输了。啊，所以一个非常富有的人偶然遇到一个非常贫穷的女孩，然后最终基本上结婚了，我想，这就是电影所暗示的。所以我用这个例子来表明，这种情况在数据中发生的概率极低，尽管不是零。
But of course, we call it a Cinderella story precisely because it's unusual. Yeah, it's a sort of, you know, underdog stories. We all love underdog stories, but that doesn't make them very real. So they're very, you know, unusual, rare occurrences. So unusual, rare that we made movies about. How did you come to be studying a sort of meeting? Why were you drawn to this topic? What interests you in it? I studied wealth inequality and why wealth inequality and wealth concentration is rising over the last 20 to 30 years. And one thing that is often cited as an element that may have contributed to a rising wealth concentration is the marriage market. So, you know So people with wealth, manning other people with wealth,
但当然，我们称之为“灰姑娘故事”，正是因为它不寻常。是的，这是一种，你知道，弱者逆袭的故事。我们都喜欢弱者逆袭的故事，但这并不能让它们变得非常真实。所以它们是非常，你知道，不寻常的、罕见的事件。如此不寻常、罕见，以至于我们为它们拍了电影。你是怎么开始研究选型交配的？为什么会被这个话题吸引？你对它感兴趣什么？我研究财富不平等，以及为什么财富不平等和财富集中在过去20到30年里不断上升。而经常被引用为导致财富集中度上升的一个因素就是婚姻市场。所以，你知道，所以拥有财富的人，与拥有财富的其他人结婚，
kind of excessive date, the extent of wealth inequality or wealth concentration that you see in a society. Some time ago, Luigi spotted some very unusual data that allowed him to quantify the extent of a sort of mating in society. The data came from Norway. Why Norway? Well, in most countries, it's hard to find precise data on the socioeconomic backgrounds of people.
某种程度上加剧了你在社会中看到的财富不平等或财富集中的程度。前段时间，路易吉发现了一些非常不寻常的数据，使他能够量化社会中选型交配的程度。这些数据来自挪威。为什么是挪威？嗯，在大多数国家，很难找到关于人们社会经济背景的精确数据。
Most of us don't broadcast our bank balances, and the ones who tell us how rich they are are often narcissists who might be lying. But in Norway, banks directly report to the government about how much citizens have in their accounts. And then the other thing that is important is that Norway has a world tax, unlike the US, unlike many other countries. So the tax authority collects very detailed information on the assets you own, and pretty much all the assets you own.
我们大多数人不会广播我们的银行余额，而那些告诉我们他们有多富有的人往往是可能在撒谎的自恋者。但在挪威，银行直接向政府报告公民账户里有多少钱。然后另一件重要的事情是，挪威有财富税，这与美国不同，与许多其他国家也不同。所以税务机关收集了关于你拥有的资产的非常详细的信息，几乎是你拥有的所有资产。
So it could be housing, it could be the value of your stock. Market portfolio, it could be the bonds, it could be the value of private business, etc. So you have a very exhausting information on the assets that people own and also the debt that they have. Luigi and his colleagues collected 11 years worth of tax data? It included the income and assets of over five million people, the rich, the poor, and everyone in between. Next, they looked at marriage records. So what we did, first of all, was to look at the wealth of the assets that people have used before they get married. And in one advantage of this data is that you observe people before they enter their formal marriage relationship. So you know, you know, eventually if you're going to marry X, you know, how much income a wealth that
所以它可以是住房，可以是你的股票市场投资组合的价值，可以是债券，可以是私人企业的价值等等。所以你拥有关于人们拥有的资产以及他们背负的债务的非常详尽的信息。路易吉和他的同事收集了11年的税务数据？它包括了超过五百万人的收入和资产，富人、穷人以及介于两者之间的所有人。接下来，他们查看了婚姻记录。所以我们首先做的是，查看人们在结婚前拥有的财富或资产。而这些数据的一个优势是，你可以在人们进入正式婚姻关系之前观察他们。所以你知道，你知道，最终如果你要和X结婚，你知道，X在婚前拥有的收入或财富是可以观察到的。你在挪威关于谁和谁结婚方面首先发现了什么？
X person has before the marriage is observed. What did you find first in terms of who was marrying whom in Norway? find first in terms of who was marrying whom in Norway? So we find that, you know, if you rank people according to the wealth they have before marriage, then someone who has a wealth of a hundred will tend to marry with a high probability someone with a wealth of a hundred. And similarly, someone at the bottom will tend to marry someone who's similar to them. That sense we find strong evidence of a self-denimating. I just want to spend a moment talking about how this actually unfolds in real life. I mean, it's possible that people in Norway are actually asking one another,
在挪威关于谁和谁结婚方面首先发现了什么？所以我们发现，你知道，如果你根据人们婚前的财富对他们进行排名，那么拥有100财富的人倾向于以高概率与拥有100财富的人结婚。同样，处于底层的人倾向于与和他们相似的人结婚。从这个意义上说，我们发现了选型交配的有力证据。我只是想花点时间谈谈这在现实生活中是如何展开的。我的意思是，挪威人有可能真的在问对方，
how much money do you have in your bank balance? And basically saying, okay, you're on my list, you're off my list, but I suspect it doesn't happen at that level where someone's saying, show me your bank balance, and I'm going to decide whether to offer my hand in marriage or ask for your hand in marriage. I don't think it happens at that level. How is this happening with if those conversations are not transparent and on the surface? How is this matching actually taking place, do you think, Luigi? It seems to say you make this comment because actually know what that's happened. We have a lot of information. Because you know, we text records are actually public. Oh, I see. They're not just shared with the government. They're actually public.
你的银行余额里有多少钱？基本上说，好吧，你在我的名单上，你不在我的名单上，但我怀疑它不会发生在那种层面，即有人说，给我看你的银行余额，我将决定是否提供我的手请求婚姻或请求你的手请求婚姻。我不认为它发生在那个层面。如果这些对话不是透明的和表面的，这是怎么发生的？你认为这种匹配实际上是如何发生的，路易吉？似乎你说你发表这个评论是因为实际上知道发生了什么。我们有很多信息。因为你知道，税务记录实际上是公开的。哦，我明白了。它们不仅仅是与政府共享。它们实际上是公开的。
Yeah. So if you have an internet, you know, access to the internet, and you have a social security number registered with the Norwegian tax authority, you can go on the web, enter the main or the person kind of looking for, and that would speed out information about assets, the income, the taxes they pay, the year they're born, where they live and so forth. So you have a pretty, if you want. I mean, the interesting thing is that the gum and that some part realize that this was a little bit between true, even by Norwegian standards, and they changed the roles, and you know, the roles is now, yes,
是的。所以如果你有互联网，你知道，可以访问互联网，并且你有一个在挪威税务机关注册的社会安全号码，你可以上网，输入你正在寻找的人的名字，那就会吐出关于资产、收入、他们缴纳的税款、他们出生的年份、他们居住的地方等等的信息。所以如果你愿意的话，你有一个相当不错的。我的意思是，有趣的是，政府意识到这甚至按照挪威的标准也有点过分了，他们改变了规则，你知道，规则现在是，是的，
you can still search, but the person you search will know who's searching for them. So this discourage almost immediately a lot of the searches, you know, your neighbor, your colleague, and so on. Of course, what happens in Norway doesn't happen in most places. But Luigi says you don't need to access someone's detailed financial information to glean how wealthy they are. So you can infer how wealthy Simon is by the card that they drive or the kind of causes that they wear or things of that sort. So, or the type of indication they have, or what they can afford, where they go on vacation, etc.
你仍然可以搜索，但你搜索的人会知道是谁在搜索他们。所以这几乎立即阻止了大量的搜索，你知道，你的邻居、你的同事等等。当然，发生在挪威的事情在大多数地方并没有发生。但路易吉说，你不需要访问某人的详细财务信息来推断他们有多富有。所以你可以通过他们驾驶的汽车，或者他们穿的衣服，或者这类事情来推断西蒙有多富有。所以，或者他们拥有的教育类型，或者他们负担得起什么，他们去哪里度假等等。
So, there's a lot of signals of display of wealth that comes from the things that you spend your money on. One of the other things that you found in your paper fascinatingly was not just wealthy people pulling their wealth together, but what happens to that wealth afterwards? Can you talk about what you found Luigi? We find that people are really good at generating high return for their assets, tend to marry people very good at making a high return from their assets. There is, but there seems to be a certain
所以，有很多财富展示的信号来自于你花钱买的东西。你在论文中发现的另一件令人着迷的事情不仅仅是富人将他们的财富汇集在一起，而是之后这些财富发生了什么？你能谈谈你发现了什么吗，路易吉？我们发现，非常擅长为他们的资产产生高回报的人，倾向于与非常擅长从他们的资产中获得高回报的人结婚。有，但似乎有一种
in mating or returns on top of the assault in mating wealth. Can I just ask you to try and speculate on what could be driving that? Because let's say, I show up at a date with a very fancy car, and my date shows up at the date in a driving a very fancy car. We can both infer that the other person is wealthy.
在财富选型交配之上的回报选型交配。我能请你试着推测一下是什么在驱动这个吗？因为假设，我开着一辆非常豪华的车去约会，而我的约会对象开着一辆非常豪华的车去约会。我们都可以推断出对方很富有。
But how in the world would I know that my date actually has a high rate of return on his or her investment? And how would my date figure that out about me? You know, if you date someone, you typically don't marry a person after one day, you know, after going out one night. I mean, yes, there are the shotgun larges from Vegas, but you know, we're not talking about that. We're talking about normal people. So normal people, you know, kind of dates, sometimes go habit for a long time. So they learn a lot about what the other person does with his money before they actually
但我到底怎么会知道我的约会对象实际上在他的投资上有很高的回报率呢？而我的约会对象又是如何发现关于我的这一点的呢？你知道，如果你和某人约会，你通常不会在一天之后，你知道，在出去一个晚上之后就和那个人结婚。我的意思是，是的，有来自拉斯维加斯的闪电式婚姻，但你知道，我们不是在谈论那个。我们是在谈论正常人。所以正常人，你知道，约会，有时会持续很长时间。所以他们在实际合并他们的财富之前，会了解对方如何处理他的钱。
merge their wealth. And I use the example of, you know, Lady Mary in downtown Habby, you know, Lady Mary at some point has to Mary and because it's a society where, you know, she will marry some other rich guy, certainly made him wealthy as guaranteed. So the question is, you know, she has two potential students. So one is a guy who is really good at managing his, you know, estate and the other one is, you know, really someone who is an aristocrat. He's very wealthy, but he was the money in a few ways.
我用的是，你知道，《唐顿庄园》里玛丽小姐的例子，你知道，玛丽小姐在某个时候必须结婚，因为这是一个社会，你知道，她会嫁给其他富人，选型交配是有保证的。所以问题是，你知道，她有两个潜在的追求者。一个是真的很擅长管理他的，你知道，庄园的人，另一个是，你知道，真的是一个贵族。他很富有，但他以几种方式挥霍钱财。
And so the question that we ask rhetorically is, OK, should she marry the guy who is not very good at managing his wealth? And the answer is, and this is something that we provide evidence for, the answer, which kind of person should she pick, is, well, it depends on who's going to end up managing the resources of the family after the family's four. So, in those families, where, of course, there is a lot of wealth, you have greater incentives to have, you know, efficiency. So, to have the portfolio being managed by someone is really good, now to start with.
所以我们反问的问题是，好吧，她应该嫁给那个不擅长管理财富的人吗？答案是，这是我们提供证据的东西，答案是，她应该选择哪种人，嗯，这取决于谁最终会在家庭财富形成后管理家庭的资源。所以，在那些家庭中，当然，有很多财富，你有更大的动力去拥有，你知道，效率。所以，让投资组合由一个真的很擅长的人来管理，现在从一开始就是这样。
really good and to start with. What Luigi is saying is that when wealthy people marry other wealthy people, the shared family wealth is invariably managed by the person with a better head for money. Maybe someone with an entrepreneurial streak or a sophisticated investor. A sort of mating ensures that with each generation, wealth not only merges with wealth, but that wealth accumulation accelerates on top of wealth. And this has profound consequences.
真的很擅长，从一开始就是这样。路易吉所说的是，当富人与富人结婚时，共享的家庭财富总是由那个更有理财头脑的人管理。也许是一个有创业精神的人或一个老练的投资者。选型交配确保了每一代人，财富不仅与财富合并，而且财富积累在财富之上加速。这产生了深远的后果。
When you emerge your wealth, you have immediately a scale effect. You have accelerating forms of wealth inequality. So this is an explosive form of wealth inequality. So, you know, this is an explosive form of wealth acceleration. And that's exactly what, you know, people have seen if you look at work by economies like Emmanuel Saez and Gabriel Zuchman, that is exactly what are the findings they have for the United States. So in the last 30 years, the degree of concentration
当你合并你的财富时，你立即产生了一个规模效应。你有了加速形式的财富不平等。所以这是一种爆炸性的财富不平等形式。所以，你知道，这是一种爆炸性的财富加速形式。而这正是，你知道，如果你看像伊曼纽尔·赛斯和加布里埃尔·祖克曼这样的经济学家的工作，人们所看到的，这正是他们在美利坚合众国发现的结果。所以在过去30年里，财富分配的集中度
of world distribution has been accelerating at a very fast rate. I'm wondering besides your academic work and your research, do you see the effects of a sort of mating around you, Luigi? Do you notice that in your social circle? I mean, I feel like as I read this paper, I started to think about the people who I know. And it's remarkable how similar so many of the couples are whom
一直以非常快的速度加速。我想知道，除了你的学术工作和研究之外，你在你周围看到了选型交配的影响吗，路易吉？你在你的社交圈里注意到了吗？我的意思是，我觉得当我读这篇论文时，我开始思考我认识的人。而且令人惊讶的是，我认识的这么多夫妇是多么相似。
I know. You know, this is whether they're older or younger. People tend to come from the same background. Is that the same for you? Oh, yeah. So, I mean, we have extreme cases like, you know, professors in the part that been married to other professors. So, that's an extreme form of sort in mating on education. And in fact, they have students working on that. I think it's very rare for people, you know, who get to the top of the distribution of education to be married with someone from, you know, high school degree degree or high school dropout.
你知道，这无论是他们年长还是年轻。人们倾向于来自相同的背景。这对你来说也是一样的吗？哦，是的。所以，我的意思是，我们有极端的例子，比如，你知道，部门里的教授嫁给了其他教授。所以，这是教育上的一种极端形式的选型交配。事实上，他们有学生在研究这个。我认为对于那些，你知道，达到教育分布顶端的人来说，与一个拥有高中学位或高中辍学的人结婚是非常罕见的。
If you look around you and you find some example, you know that these are very rare exceptions. So yeah, certainly, meetings everywhere. When we talk about wealth inequality, we typically think of systemic causes. The housing market, student debt, the tax system. We rarely think about how our own decisions, decisions that are very personal involving whom we love and whom we marry could accelerate inequality. When we come back, if our personal connections can exacerbate the problem of inequality, surprising new research suggests personal connections might also be the answer to the problem.
如果你环顾四周，发现一些例子，你知道这些是非常罕见的例外。所以是的，当然，选型交配无处不在。当我们谈论财富不平等时，我们通常会想到系统性的原因。房地产市场、学生债务、税收制度。我们很少想到我们自己的决定，那些非常个人的决定，涉及我们爱谁和我们与谁结婚，可能会加速不平等。当我们回来时，如果我们的个人联系会加剧不平等的问题，令人惊讶的新研究表明，个人联系也可能是解决这个问题的答案。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When two people with similar interests, backgrounds and temperaments get together romantically, we're often inclined to say, the couple is made for each other. What is harder to see are the downstream effects of what is known as a sortative mating. Our tendency to connect with others like ourselves can greatly exacerbate inequality over time. This may be one reason why research by the Harvard economist Raj Shetty and his colleagues has found that where you are born can shape your outcomes in life. If you are born in a poor neighborhood and hang out with other people who are poor,
你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当两个有相似兴趣、背景和气质的人在浪漫关系中走到一起时，我们往往倾向于说，这对夫妇是天造地设的一对。更难看到的是所谓的“选型交配”的下游影响。我们倾向于与像我们自己一样的人建立联系，这会随着时间的推移极大地加剧不平等。这可能是哈佛经济学家拉杰·切蒂及其同事的研究发现你出生的地方可以塑造你人生结果的原因之一。如果你出生在一个贫穷的社区，并和其他贫穷的人混在一起，
it's a lot harder to climb the socio-economic ladder than if you are a rich person born into a wealthy community. Here is Raj from our episode some years ago called Zipco Destiny. So think about upward mobility in the context of the classic Rags to Rich's kind of notion. Suppose you're a kid growing up in a low income family, say the bottom fifth of the income distribution. What are your odds of reaching the top fifth of the income distribution, making that leap from the bottom to the top?
比起出生在富裕社区的富人，你想要攀登社会经济阶梯要困难得多。这是拉杰几年前在我们名为《邮编即命运》的节目中的话。所以，考虑一下经典“白手起家”概念背景下的向上流动性。假设你是一个在低收入家庭长大的孩子，比如收入分配的后五分之一。你达到收入分配前五分之一的几率是多少，即实现从底层到顶层的跨越？
So it turns out if you look at the US as a whole, that number is seven and a half percent, seven and a half percent of kids who start out in a relatively low income family will end up reaching the top fifth on average. That doesn't paint a very positive picture of economic mobility in the United States. Recently, however, new research suggests a way out of the trap. To understand what it is, I want to take you back to the early 1980s and the story of
所以事实证明，如果你看整个美国，那个数字是7.5%，7.5%的从相对低收入家庭开始的孩子最终会达到前五分之一。这并没有描绘出一幅关于美国经济流动性的非常积极的图景。然而，最近，新的研究提出了一种摆脱陷阱的方法。为了理解它是什么，我想带你回到20世纪80年代初，以及一个
a man named Matthew Jackson. So this was actually in late high school and then if the first couple of years in back to the early 1980s and the story of a man named Matthew Jackson. So this was actually in late high school and then if the first couple of years in college I was working in warehouses in Chicago, mostly unloading. Trucks was one of the few jobs that you could get without a connection. I needed the money to help pay for college And so it certainly wasn't a glamorous job. I mean, it was what you would expect. So it was a warehouse that sold catalog stuff
名叫马修·杰克逊的人的故事。所以这实际上是在高中后期，然后如果前几年回到20世纪80年代初，以及一个名叫马修·杰克逊的人的故事。所以这实际上是在高中后期，然后如果前几年在大学里，我在芝加哥的仓库工作，主要是卸货。卡车是你可以不用关系就能找到的少数工作之一。我需要钱来帮助支付大学学费，所以这当然不是一份光鲜的工作。我的意思是，它就是你所期望的那样。所以这是一个销售目录产品的仓库，
and we would ship televisions, household wears, diapers, food products, all kinds of things would come in these trucks. And our job was to sit there for hours and wait till a truck came and then get the truck unloaded in half an hour and then wait for the next one and it was, you know, hard work physically, but mentally it was just extremely boring. Matthew's managers had, shall we say, a less than trusting attitude toward him and his fellow blue collar workers. We had lie detector tests that we were given every couple of weeks, you know, because I think the main thing
我们会运送电视机、家庭用品、尿布、食品，各种各样的东西都会装在这些卡车里。我们的工作就是坐在那里几个小时，等卡车来，然后在半小时内把卡车卸完，然后再等下一辆，你知道，体力上很辛苦，但精神上却极其无聊。马修的经理们对他的同事和蓝领工人们有一种，我们姑且说，不太信任的态度。我们每隔几周就会进行测谎测试，你知道，因为我认为公司实际上担心的主要事情是失去，他们损失了很多钱给员工。所以对于卸卡车的人来说，把东西卸到一边并逃脱惩罚是很容易的。这是从卡车上掉下来的袋子的特权。没错。所以这显然是一个，你知道，改变了我对工作以及我想用我的生活做什么的看法的位置。马修热爱学术，想做他觉得有启发性的工作，但事实证明
that the company actually worried about was losing, they lost a lot of money to employ ethos. So it's easy for somebody unloading a truck to just unload something to the side and get away with it. It's a privilege of being bag falling off the truck. Exactly. So it was, you know, it was clearly a position that, you know, changed my perspective on work and what I wanted to do with my life. Matthew loved academics and wanted to do work that he found stimulating, but that turned out
这真的很难找到。所以当谈到大学，支付私立大学的费用时，需要的钱比我们能负担得起的要多得多。所以，你知道，我在高中时工作。我做了这些卡车运输工作，实际上在周末，我会在当地一家医疗中心做夜班看守。那是我当时做过的薪水最高的工作，也就是，你知道，我午夜进去，然后一直待到早上8点，只是在楼里走来走去，确保没有人闯入。你知道，所以就是像那样的工作，
to be really hard to find. And so when it came to college, to paying for a private university, there was a lot more money needed than we could afford. And so, you know, I worked during high school. I worked these trucking jobs and actually on weekends, I would work a night watchman shift at a local medical center. That was the best paying job I ever had at that time, which was, you know, I'd go in at midnight and then stay there until 8 a.m. and just walk around the building, making sure nobody was breaking in. You know, so it was jobs like that that were
没有关系也能得到。所以，你知道，它们是支付报酬的工作，并且，你知道，帮助为大学存钱。那一定也很无聊吧？从午夜到早上8点走来走去，确保没有人闯入大楼。是的，最糟糕的是你做了一班卸卡车的工作，然后又去医疗中心过夜的那天。到第二天早上，你就完全崩溃了。这很艰难。像许多没有关系的人一样，马修
available without connections. And so, you know, they were jobs that paid and, you know, helped save money for universities. That must have been pretty deadly boring as well, right? Walking around from midnight to 8 o'clock in the morning to make sure no one's breaking into a building. Yeah, the worst was a day where you did a shift of unloading trucks and then went to the medical center overnight. And by the next morning, you just completely went out. It was tough. Like many people without connections, Matthew
没有办法进入他知道自己会擅长的那种工作。但那在他上大学后的一天改变了。他正在和他的本科导师雨果·桑纳钦聊天，谈论他的暑期计划。所以有一天我在雨果的办公室和他谈话，他说，嗯，你这个夏天打算做什么？我说，嗯，我会回芝加哥去卸卡车。他说，不，不，不，不，不。你知道，我们要给你找一份你真正能学到东西的工作。他真的在我还在他办公室的时候拿起电话，打给了他在芝加哥的朋友盖伦·伯克哈特，那是他从马萨诸塞大学阿默斯特分校时期就认识的朋友，说，你知道，我有一个本科生，他需要一些工作，他住在芝加哥，盖伦当时在芝加哥商品交易所工作，盖伦说，是的，我们可以想办法。当马修回到芝加哥时，他开始在芝加哥商品交易所工作。突然间，他意识到他的数学技能可以在经济学领域得到应用。这份暑期工作被证明是变革性的。你知道，那在工作类型方面简直是一个不可思议的改变。而且我实际上是在为他们做研究，这最终成为了我写的一篇论文，并影响了我作为博士生所做的研究，所以它确实改变了生活
didn't have a way of breaking into the kind of job he knew he would be good at. But that changed one day after he got to college. He was having a chat with his undergraduate advisor Hugo Sonnanchine about his summer plans. So I was having a talk with Hugo one day in his office and he said, well, what are you going to do this summer? And I said, well, I'll go back to Chicago and unload trucks. And he said, no, no, no, no, no. You know, we're going to get you a job that you'll actually learn something from. And he literally picked up the phone while I was in his office and called a friend of his in Chicago, Galen Burkehart, who had been a friend of his from his years at University of
在很多方面。那次与他导师的偶然谈话改变了马修的人生轨迹。他后来成为了一名受人尊敬的经济学家，最终进入了斯坦福大学。我认为我们很容易低估我们的人生轨迹在多大程度上是由我们在朋友和家人方面的联系决定的，以及这些联系是多么关键，你知道，因为并不是每天这些都很重要，但偶尔它们很重要，然后它们以非常大的方式重要。所以，你知道，没有那种联系，很可能我就不会做那些工作
Massachusetts Amherst and said, you know, I've got this undergraduate, he needs some work, he lives in Chicago, Gailin was working in Chicago Mercantile Exchange and Gailin said, yeah, we can figure out something. When Matthew returned to Chicago, he started working at the Chicago Mercantile Exchange. All of a sudden, he realized that his math skills could be put to use in the field of economics. The summer job proved to be transformative. You know, that was just an incredible change in terms of the kind of work I was doing. And I was actually doing research for them, which eventually became a paper that I wrote and played into the research I did as a PhD student, so it was really life-changing
在夏天，我也不会，你知道，有那种经历，它也不会打开我的眼睛看到研究的可能性。我就不会读博士了。你知道，它把我放在了一条不同的道路上。没有那个，我可能就会回去，再在仓库工作一个夏天，然后，你知道，在那之后会发生什么谁知道呢。
in many ways. That chance conversation with his advisor changed the trajectory of Matthew's life. He went on to become a respected economist, eventually finding his way to Stanford University. I think it's easy for us to underestimate how much our trajectory in life is determined by the connections that we have in terms of friends and family and how critical those are, you know, because it's not like every day these matter, but occasionally they matter and then they matter in a very big way. So, you know, without that connection, it's possible that I wouldn't have done that work
但那种联系，你知道，它们在它们所做的改变方面是不频繁的，但它们在那些时间点上可能是巨大的改变。你是否能迈出第一步，真的非常重要，而且它确实取决于我们的网络。所以故事中另一个让我跳出来的元素是，雨果和盖伦一起上学，当然他们一起上学并不是为了有一天雨果会把你介绍给盖伦。他们没有提前25年计划。
in the summers and I wouldn't have, you know, had that experience and it wouldn't have opened my eyes to research possibilities. I wouldn't have done a PhD. You know, it put me on a different road. And without that, I probably would have gone back and worked in the warehouse another summer and then, you know, who knows what would have happened after that.
所以这是一个偶然，他们一起上学的事实可能和任何其他事情一样是由偶然驱动的，但他们那次偶然的相遇最终在你的生活中扮演了关键角色。是的，是的。而且我认为，你知道，这是关于我们的网络需要理解的一件重要的事情，你知道，它们并不一定是以这种方式优化的，
But those kinds of connections, you know, they're infrequent in terms of the changes that they make, but they can be big changes at those points in time. Whether or not you get your foot in the door or not, is really so vital, and it really depends on our networks. So another element of the story that jumps out at me is that Hugo and Galen went to school together and of course they didn't go to school together in order that one day Hugo would introduce you to Galen. They didn't plan 25 years ahead.
你知道，我建立的联系给了我信息，可以帮助我的学生，可以帮助我的同事。当我思考，哦，我应该去参加这个会议吗，我会学到新东西吗？我通常是为自己考虑这个。我没有想，哦，也许我会学到这个东西，我可以告诉某某人。所以这些互动带来的全部价值
So this was a chance, the fact that they were going to school together was probably driven by chance as much as anything else, but that chance encountered that they had ended up playing a pivotal role in your life. Yes, yeah. And I think, you know, that's one thing that is important to understand about our networks is that, you know, that they're not necessarily optimized in the sense that,
以及伸出援手的重要性，这对更广泛社会的价值并不是必然支配人们选择的东西。当他们决定，哦，我应该去参加这个吗？或者我应该去见这个人吗？或者给这个人打电话有意义吗？我是否要跟进这段友谊等等？所以有很多事情我们做
you know, connections that I make give me information that can help my students and can help my colleagues. And when I'm thinking about, oh, should I go to this conference and am I going to learn something new? I'm usually thinking about this for myself. I'm not thinking, oh, maybe I'll learn this thing, which I can actually tell so and so about. And so the full value of these kinds of interactions
并没有对此进行优化。而偶然的友谊非常重要，可能会产生很多后果，但当我们建立关系时，它们并没有被完全考虑在内。这意味着我们都在以某种方式低估和缩小我们的网络，并丰富我们自己。扩大我们的网络并丰富我们自己。马修指出的是，社交网络有连锁反应。我可能认为我选择友谊只会影响我和我的朋友，
and the importance of reaching out, the value of that to the greater society isn't something that's necessarily governing people's choices. When they're deciding, oh, should I go and do this? Or should I go and meet this person? Or is it makes sense to call this person? And do I follow through this friendship and so forth? So there's a lot of things that we do
但事实上，这些选择可以深刻地塑造未来其他人的生活。未来其他人的生活。当我们回来时，如果我们的友谊和浪漫依恋可能无意中成为分裂和不平等的根源，马修的研究发现它们也可能是联系和机会的驱动力。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。当今世界上一些最大的问题是管理不善和腐败的结果。但也有许多严重的问题源于人类思维的内部结构和倾向。
that aren't optimizing on that. And the serendipitous relationships matter a lot and can have a lot of consequences, but they're not something that's fully accounted for when we form our relationships. And so that means that somehow we're all underforming and under broadening our networks and enriching ourselves. broadening our networks and enriching ourselves. What Matthew was pointing out is that social networks have ripple effects. I may think that my choice of friendship influences only me and my friends,
其中一种强大的倾向是，我们会被在某些方面与我们相似的人所吸引。这是一种被称为“同质性”的现象。在斯坦福大学，马修·杰克逊说这在日常生活中发生得如此频繁，以至于我们大多数人甚至没有意识到我们在这样做。如果你走进一个会议、一个房间或一个聚会，那里有你不认识的人，你的自然倾向之一就是开始尝试寻找共同点。哦，你问人们问题，一旦你找到共同点，你就会真正专注于此，对吧？如果你发现你们都来自同一个州或家乡，或者你们在某个时候都上过同一所学校，
but in fact, those choices can profoundly shape the lives of other people down the road. the lives of other people down the road. When we come back, if our friendships and romantic attachments can unintentionally be the source of division and inequality, Matthews researchers found that they can also be drivers of connection and opportunity. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Some of the biggest problems in the world today are the result of mismanagement and corruption. But there are also many serious problems that stem from the internal architecture and predispositions of the human mind.
或者你们都认识同一个共同的朋友，这些就成了让你感觉舒服得多的点，因为现在你们有话可聊，有共同点。它帮助你理解对方。它帮助你理解他们的观点。它减少了不确定性。从心理学上讲，处于一个你理解
One of those powerful predispositions is that we gravitate toward people who are similar to us in some way. It's a phenomenon known as homophily. At Stanford University, Matthew Jackson says this happens so regularly in daily life that most of us don't even realize we do it. If you walk into a conference or a room or a meeting where there's people that you don't know, one of your natural tendencies is to start trying to find common ground. Oh, you ask people questions, and then once you find something in common, you really zero in on that, right? If you find that you both came from the same state or hometown, or that you both went to the same school at some point,
对方并且知道他们的背景和观点的情况，比遇到一个你根本不了解并且可能有与你截然不同观点的人要舒服得多。那是一种更难处的情况。所以我们自然倾向于那些事情，尽管这并不一定符合我们的长期利益。所以我想让你谈谈这一点，即这些力量在某种程度上
or that you both know somebody in common, those become points where you feel much more comfortable because now you've got something to talk about and something in common. It helps you understand the other person. It helps you understand their perspective. It reduces uncertainty. Psychologically, it's just much more comfortable to be in a situation where you understand the
或者你们有共同认识的人，这些都会成为让你感到更自在的切入点，因为现在你们有了共同话题和共同点。这有助于你了解对方，理解他们的视角，并减少不确定性。从心理学上讲，身处一个你了解对方的环境中，确实会让人感到舒服得多。
other person and you know what their background is and their viewpoint than meeting somebody who you don't really understand at all and might have very different perspectives than you. That's a harder kind of situation to be in. And so we naturally tend to those things, even though that's not necessarily the best thing in our long-term interest. So I want you to talk a little bit about that, which is that these forces are in some way
比起遇到一个你完全不了解、且观点可能与你大相径庭的人，了解对方的背景和观点会让你更自在。面对后者那种情况会更困难。因此，我们自然会倾向于那些熟悉的事物，尽管这未必符合我们的长远利益。所以我想请你谈谈这一点，即这些力量在某种程度上
such natural forces of feeling saying, I want to be comfortable around other people, and someone who basically shares my outlook or likes the same sports team or comes from the same geographic background or has the same racial background or income background. I feel more comfortable around this person and so I'm going to spend time with them. That very natural thing ends up playing this really consequential role when multiplied across an entire society. Can you talk about how this homophily essentially ends up
这种自然的感受力量会说，我想在其他人身边感到舒适，或者想和那些基本与我志趣相投、喜欢同一支运动队、来自同一地理背景、拥有相同种族背景或收入背景的人在一起。我觉得和这个人在一起更自在，所以我愿意花时间和他们相处。这种非常自然的事情，当在整个社会中被放大时，最终会起到非常重要的作用。你能谈谈这种同质性最终是如何导致
segregating groups of people and sealing off aspects of society or access to income mobility for people who are especially poor? Yeah, so I think one thing that's pretty amazing in the US is that there's a lot of heterogeneity. Different parts of the country have very different mobility patterns. You're much more likely to advance if you live and say the upper Midwest than if you live in the deep south.
群体隔离，并封锁了社会层面或贫困人口获得收入流动的机会吗？是的，我认为美国有一点非常令人惊奇，那就是存在很大的异质性。全国不同地区的流动模式截然不同。如果你住在中西部北部，比住在深南部更有可能获得晋升。
There are places where you see connections across class lines, but there's a lot where you don't. There's a huge amount of homophily by economic class, and that tends to be in areas where you have very low mobility. When you look at it in terms of how predictive our parents' income of children's income, the U.S. doesn't do so well. The chance that you look like your parents is fairly high. And that means that, you know, for some reasons, children, their future is heavily determined
有些地方你可以看到跨阶层的联系，但也有很多地方看不到。经济阶层之间存在大量的同质性，这往往出现在流动性非常低的地区。当你从父母收入对子女收入的预测能力来看时，美国的表现并不好。你看起来像你父母的可能性相当高。这意味着，你知道，由于某些原因，孩子们的未来在很大程度上是由
by the conditions that they're born into and the situations that they're born into. And at a fundamental level, there's something about that that rankles, doesn't it, which is that I think many of us imagine that we should not be constrained by the circumstances of our birth, by the accident of birth. We think that that should not determine what happens in terms of the outcomes in life. But really what you're saying is, accidents of birth are playing an enormous role in the likelihood of people's economic and social success in a country like the United States. Yes, definitely.
他们出生的条件和环境所决定的。从根本上讲，这让人感到不安，不是吗？因为我认为我们许多人认为我们不应该受到出生环境或出生偶然性的限制。我们认为这不应该决定生活的结果。但你真正想说的是，出生的偶然性在像美国这样的国家，对人们经济和社会成功的可能性起着巨大的作用。是的，绝对是这样。
And in fact, I think, you know, when we think about the philosophy of it and the moral aspects of it, when people object to inequality, a lot of what we're objecting to is unequal opportunities because it's saying, you were just born in a circumstances no matter how hard you worked, you were going to be behind. And that's different than saying, oh, you know, so and so happened to get lucky or so and so is really talented. Obviously Michael Jordan can play basketball at a level that other humans can't, right? And we don't envy him.
事实上，我认为，当我们思考其哲学和道德层面时，当人们反对不平等时，我们反对的很大一部分是不平等的机遇，因为它意味着，无论你多么努力，你出生在某种环境中，你就注定会落后。这与说“哦，某某人碰巧运气好”或“某某人真的很有天赋”是不同的。显然，迈克尔·乔丹打篮球的水平是其他人无法企及的，对吧？我们并不嫉妒他。
Well maybe we envy him, but we don't say, oh, he doesn't deserve that what he earned from that. That's very different from saying somebody who's born in a community and never got a chance because of where they started. As they try to figure out how something works or how to fix a problem, scientists sometimes look for what's called positive deviants. Let's say a virus is spreading. You can study people who fall sick to figure out the nature of the pathogen.
好吧，也许我们嫉妒他，但我们不会说，哦，他不配得到他通过努力换来的东西。这与说一个人出生在某个社区，因为起点问题而从未获得机会是完全不同的。当科学家试图弄清楚某件事是如何运作或如何解决问题时，有时会寻找所谓的“正向偏差”。假设病毒正在传播。你可以研究那些生病的人，以找出病原体的性质。
But you can also study people who don't fall sick, the positive deviance, and ask what their secret is. If you can figure it out, the insight can help you keep other people from falling sick. In this case, the word deviant is not being used as a pejorative, but as something often accolade. Matthew and other researchers knew from the data that most kids who are born poor don't break into the ranks of the rich, but a small number do. What was their secret? Matthew's own life had been transformed by a chance
但你也可以研究那些没有生病的人，即“正向偏差”，并询问他们的秘诀是什么。如果你能弄清楚，这种洞察力可以帮助你防止其他人患病。在这种情况下，“偏差”一词并非贬义，而往往是一种赞誉。马修和其他研究人员从数据中得知，大多数出生贫困的孩子无法跻身富人行列，但少数人做到了。他们的秘诀是什么？马修自己的人生因一次偶然的
conversation and the fact that his college advisor was friends from his college days with someone who worked at the Chicago Mercantile Exchange. Matthew had a hunch, the same thing, on a massive scale, might be connected to differences he was seeing in income mobility. To test this idea, he turned to Facebook. Facebook was really valuable on several dimensions. So we were actually able to look at 84% of the population of the age group we were looking at.
谈话而改变，他的大学导师与一位在芝加哥商品交易所工作的人是大学时代的朋友。马修有一种预感，同样的事情，在大规模范围内，可能与他所看到的收入流动性差异有关。为了验证这个想法，他转向了Facebook。Facebook在多个维度上都非常有价值。我们实际上能够查看我们所研究年龄段中84%的人口。
Secondly, we can see all the friendships of these people and really see who are their high school friends, who are their college friends, who are their work friends, so we can actually classify where their friendships are formed, what their networks look like. We can also begin to see a lot of demographics about the people so we can estimate their income level and get information about exactly where they live and so forth. So just putting all that information together is something that's pretty rare to have.
其次，我们可以看到这些人所有的友谊，真正看到谁是他们的高中朋友、大学朋友、工作朋友，所以我们实际上可以对他们的友谊形成地点进行分类，看看他们的社交网络是什么样的。我们还可以开始看到关于这些人的大量人口统计数据，因此我们可以估算他们的收入水平，并获得关于他们确切居住地等信息。所以，将所有这些信息汇总在一起是非常罕见的。
And it allowed us to see how those social connections actually translate into the economic outcomes. And when you look at this pattern of friendships, what do you find in terms of homophily? Yeah, so the main thing that pops out in terms of the homophily that we were looking at was take somebody who's below median income and ask what fraction of their friends are above median income. If it was a completely well mixed random world, 50% of their friends should be above median income. It's just over 38% on average. If you look at people who are above median income, it's above 70% of their friends or above median income. So there's a huge gap between what fraction of people's
这使我们能够看到这些社会联系如何转化为经济结果。当你观察这种友谊模式时，你在同质性方面发现了什么？是的，关于我们所研究的同质性，最突出的事情是：以一个收入低于中位数的人为例，问问他们的朋友中有多少比例是收入高于中位数的。如果这是一个完全混合的随机世界，他们50%的朋友应该收入高于中位数。平均而言，这个比例仅略高于38%。如果你看那些收入高于中位数的人，他们70%以上的朋友收入也高于中位数。所以，人们的朋友中收入高于中位数的比例存在巨大差距，
friends or above median income, depending on whether you're above or below yourself. And so that level of homophily is pretty strong. How did you measure people's income using Facebook data? So we inferred it. So we have locations on people people and then we have a lot of information about people, what phone they use, if they go to college, where did they go to college, it's so forth. There's just, you know, we use 22 variables, I think, in the end and a machine learning
这取决于你自己是高于还是低于中位数。因此，这种同质性水平相当强。你是如何使用Facebook数据衡量人们的收入的？我们是推断出来的。我们有人们的位置信息，然后我们有关于人们的大量信息，比如他们使用什么手机、是否上大学、在哪里上大学等等。最后我们使用了22个变量，我想，还有一个机器学习
algorithm that could basically estimate them. And we could put that together with census data. So census data goes down to a block level. So you have a very fine grade of where somebody is located. And the interesting thing about that is that if you're looking in the US and you look down to a block level, you pretty much can nail somebody's income. So putting that census data together with various variables we could observe with people in the locations, we could build a model that said, look, if you tell us these characteristics about a person, we can tell you pretty much what their income level is.
算法，基本上可以估算出来。我们可以将其与人口普查数据结合起来。人口普查数据精确到街区级别。所以你对某人的位置有非常细致的了解。有趣的是，如果你在美国观察并细化到街区级别，你几乎可以确定某人的收入。因此，将人口普查数据与我们在这些地点观察到的各种变量结合起来，我们可以建立一个模型，说：看，如果你告诉我们关于一个人的这些特征，我们几乎可以告诉你他们的收入水平。
So at one level, what you're finding in some ways using this very large sample set is essentially a large scale replication of something that we've already known in a small scale, which is that people tend to cluster together. People who are poor tend to spend, have more friends who are poor, and fewer friends who are rich. People who are richer tend to have more friends who are rich. Fewer friends who are poor.
所以从某种程度上说，你使用这个非常大的样本集所发现的，本质上是对我们已经在小范围内所知事实的大规模复制，即人们倾向于聚集在一起。穷人倾向于花更多时间与穷人交朋友，而与富人的朋友较少。较富有的人倾向于有更多的富人朋友，而较少的穷人朋友。
But you didn't just stop there. You actually went somewhere further with the study. Walk me through what you did now with all of these connections that you've established that people have or don't have. Yeah, so the, you know, the base question that we started with was, you know, what is it that predicts whether somebody who's born into the poor half of the distribution could end up in the top half of the income distribution? And in particular, there's lots of different things about a person's network and community
但你并没有止步于此。你实际上在研究中走得更远。带我了解一下你现在如何处理你所建立的这些人们拥有或没有的联系。是的，我们开始时的基本问题是，是什么预测了一个出生在收入分布后半部分的人最终能否进入收入分布的前半部分？特别是，关于一个人的网络和社区结构，有很多不同的事情你可能会认为很重要。通常被称为“社会资本”的东西，对吧？我们知道金融资本很重要。如果你有财富，那会有帮助。如果有人力资本，如果你的父母受过教育，那会有帮助。但社会资本，你的网络中什么才是重要的？三个可能性浮现出来。一个是，社区里的人都互相认识吗？
structure that you could imagine would matter. Things that are commonly referred to as social capital, right? We know financial capital matters. If you have wealth that helps you. If human capital, if your parents are educated, that's going to help you. But social capital, what is it about your network that matters? Three possibilities jumped out. One would just be, okay, does the community all know each other?
所以我们可以在Facebook数据中查看这一点，你可以直接看，如果我有两个朋友，他们彼此是朋友吗？你可以看到社区在聚类方面的紧密程度。所以这是我们可以直接衡量的事情。如果来自紧密社区的贫困孩子是那些进入高收入群体的人，那么提高收入流动性的解决方案就是鼓励更大的社区凝聚力。可能性之二，社区中更高程度的慷慨和利他主义。如果你来自一个特别友善的地方，也许
So we can look at that in a Facebook data, and you can just look at, okay, if my, I have two friends, are they friends with each other? And you can see how tightly knit communities are in terms of that clustering. So that's something we can measure directly. If poor kids from tight knit communities were the ones who made their way into upper-income groups, the solution to improve income ability would be to encourage greater community cohesion. Possibility, too, a higher degree of generosity and altruism in the community. If you come from an especially kind place, maybe there
有人和团体可以成为帮助贫困孩子成功的垫脚石。全国性的Facebook数据包含了关于不同社区人们的信息。你可以在他们的Facebook页面上看到他们是否是志愿者组织的成员，是否是某个非政府组织或慈善机构的成员。当你观察信任度或志愿服务率等事物时，这些通常与当地组织的功能运作情况以及我们地区是否有良好的机构有关。所以这些是我们通常认为在经济流动性方面会帮助人们的事情。还有第三种可能性来解释为什么某些地方的穷人能够更好地
are people and groups who can be stepping stones to help a poor kid succeed. The nationwide Facebook data contain the answer about people in different communities. You can see on their Facebook page are they part of a volunteer organization, are they part of some NGO or charity. When you look at things like the kinds of trust or volunteering rates and so forth, those are often associated with how well functioning are sort of the local organizations and do we have good institutions in our area. So those are things that we often think would help people out in terms of, you know, economic mobility. There was a third possibility to explain why poor people in some places were better able to
改变他们的经济地位。这些地方在富人和穷人之间有更多的联系。他们在群体之间建立了桥梁，抵消了同质性的影响。在这些地方，人们更有可能与背景不同的人交谈。穷人和富人互为朋友或熟人。马修称之为“经济连通性”。你可以找到没有连通性但聚类非常强的社区，或者你可以找到人们非常有公民意识但人们不聚类的地方。所以你可以在全国范围内找到这些不同组合的情况。最后，事实证明，唯一真正强有力的预测因素
transform their economic station in life. These places had more connections between rich and poor people. They had bridges between groups that counteracted the effects of homophily. In these places, people were more likely to talk to people who came from different backgrounds than themselves. Poor people and rich people counted one another as friends or acquaintances. Matthew called this economic connectedness. You can find communities where you have no connectedness, but you have very strong clustering, or you can find places where people are very civically minded, but people don't cluster. So you can find each of these in different combinations across the country. And in the end, it turns out that the only thing that really was a strong predictor
就是这种经济连通性，即穷人和富人之间是否存在友谊。马修被数据的力量震撼了。我认为令我们惊讶的事情之一，至少对我来说，是经济连通性最终对某人流动性的预测能力有多强。这意味着如果你身处一个经济连通性很强的社区，你很有可能身处一个穷人有机会成长为收入高于中位数或实现阶层跃升的社区。这种相关性也经受住了各种其他因素的考验。所以你可以加入任何你认为重要的变量，比如该地区有多穷、多不平等、
was this economic connectedness of whether or not there were friendships between the poor people and the wealthier people. Matthew was blown away by the strength of the data. I think one of the surprising things to us, at least to me, was how strongly the economic connectedness ended up predicting somebody's mobility. And that means if you're in a community where you have strong economic connectedness, you're very likely to be in a community where the poor have a chance of growing up to have above median income or sort of rising. And that correlation also was stood all kinds of other things. So you could put in whatever variables you think of how poor is the area, how unequal is
是城市还是农村、白人与黑人与西班牙裔的比例是多少？你可以查看各种不同的变量。没有一个变量具有与此相同的力量。所以我认为令人震惊的一点是它作为预测指标的强大程度。所以换句话说，如果我错了请纠正我，如果我是美国的一个穷人，我想问自己，我该如何摆脱我的经济地位并走向更好的生活？如果我必须在生活在一个非常团结、每个人都认识
the area, you know, is it urban, rural, what's the percent of white versus black versus Hispanic? You can look at all kinds of different variables. None of those really had nearly the same kind of power that this did. So I think one striking thing was how powerful that is as a predictor. So in other words, correct me if I'm wrong, but if I was a poor person in the United States and I wanted to ask myself, how can I extricate myself from my economic station and move to a better station in life? And I had to choose between living in a community that was very cohesive, where everyone knew
彼此、人们在某种程度上紧密结合的社区，或者生活在一个拥有非常好的社会服务组织和慈善机构的社区，或者生活在一个我可以真正与比我富有的人成为朋友的社区之间做出选择。我听到你所说的是，如果我身处最后一个社区，我改变社会地位的几率将是最高的。如果我有来自不同经济阶层的朋友。是的，压倒性地。事实上，人们在社区内互相了解的程度以及你是否拥有运作良好的公民组织
one another, people in some ways bonded together very tightly, or in a community that had very good social service organizations and charities, or I lived in a community that had very good social service organizations and charities or I lived in a community where I could actually be friends with people who were wealthier than I am. What I'm hearing you saying is that my odds would be the highest of actually changing my social station if I wasn't that last community. If I had friends from different economic strata. Yeah, overwhelmingly. So in fact, how well people know each other within your community and whether you have sort of well-functioning civic organizations
以及与这些组织的联系，实际上有时甚至与流动性的结果呈负相关。我认为这里发生的部分原因是，在那些较贫困的社区，你会看到更多的凝聚力，因为人们在互相帮助，你会看到更多的志愿服务，或者你可能会看到更多的志愿者组织出现，因为它们是必需的。它们提供了你原本无法获得的至关重要的帮助以及非正式的支持和服务。
and connections to those are actually sometimes even negatively correlated with the outcome in terms of mobility. And I think part of what's actually happening here is that in those poorer communities, then you see more of that cohesiveness because people are helping each other out, and you see more volunteering, or you might see more volunteer organizations appearing because they're needed. And they provide vital help and informal support and services that you don't have otherwise.
至关重要的帮助以及非正式的支持和服务，这些是你原本无法获得的。所以它们在某些方面仍然是有用的，但它们并不能帮助贫困孩子成长为，你知道，有机会不被束缚并最终超越他们的父母。经济连通性在社区中能产生多大的差异？是的，如果你带一个典型的贫困孩子，让他们拥有一个典型的富裕孩子所拥有的同样的友谊网络，那么结果的差异预测了他们终身收入20%的增长。很难找到任何具有这种终身收入变化幅度的变量。
vital help and informal support and services that you don't have otherwise. So they're still, you know, useful in some ways, but they're not helping poor kids grow up to be, you know, to have a chance at being not constrained and end up where their parents were. How much of a difference does economic connectedness make in a community? Yeah, so the difference in outcome if you take a typical poor kid and move them and give them the same friendships network that a typical rich kid would have, that predicts a 20% increase in their lifetime income. It's very hard to find any variable that has that kind of magnitude of change in lifetime income.
你认为这里在细微层面上到底发生了什么？当人们拥有这些跨社会经济地位的友谊时，你认为到底发生了什么？他们只是获得了人脉吗？他们获得了工作机会吗？你认为是什么真正改变了他们的生活结果？我认为，正如许多事情一样，这是多种因素共同作用的结果。
What do you think is actually happening at a granular level here? When people have these cross-SES, cross-social economic status friendships, what exactly do you think is happening? Are they just getting contacts? Are they getting leads to jobs? What do you think is actually changing their life outcomes? I think it's, you know, as with many things, it's a combination that matters.
那些至关重要的机会可能很少见，但确实很重要。你知道，可能是10年后，我有一个以前的高中同学，我失业了，我可以打电话给他，说，哦，我知道你在那家银行工作，你能给我一份工作吗？他们可以答应。
There's those vital opportunities that might be rare, but it can matter. You know, it could be 10 years down the line that I have a former high school friend and I'm out of the job and I can call him up and say, oh, you know, I know you work at this bank, could you give me a job there? And they can say yes.
所以可能是这样的事情，但也可能只是我们在高中时获得的信息。我是否看到其他孩子上大学？我是否看到了他们上大学需要什么？我是否看到他们之后真的找到了工作？我看到他们在做什么？我设想自己做什么？很多这些都是由那个社区形成的。
So it could be something like that, but it could also be just the information that we have when we're in high school. And am I seeing other kids go to college? Did I see what it took for them to go to college? Do I see them actually getting jobs afterwards? And what do I see them doing? What do I envision myself doing? A lot of that is formed by that community.
我认为当你把所有这些事情放在一起时，你知道，特别是在早期，它们只是自我放大，对吧？所以你学习得越多，你就能学得越多，你进步的机会就越多，你结交的朋友就越多，他们也都在上那些为上大学做准备的课程等等。
And I think when you put all these things together, you know, especially at an early age, they just amplify themselves, right? So the more you study, the more you can study, the more chance you have of advancing, the more friends you're gonna make who are also taking classes that are, you know, preparatory for going to college and so forth.
所以这一切都相互作用，然后通过那些友谊在你的余生中持续下去，为你提供机会和其他一切。我认为我们所有人都可以试着思考一下是什么在限制我们的网络，我们什么时候有机会稍微走出我们通常所做的，拓宽视野，跨越任何可能重要的鸿沟。
So it all plays into itself, and then it continues throughout your lifetime in terms of those friendships then giving you opportunities and everything else. I think just all of us can try to think a little bit about what is it that's limiting our networks, how can we do when are there opportunities for us to step out a little bit from what we normally do and broaden those horizons and bridge across whatever gap it is that might matter.
想要和像我们一样的人在一起是很自然的。加入读书俱乐部或观鸟小组，寻找志同道合、背景和性格相同的人，这并不会让你成为一个坏人。但这种非常人性化的冲动，在国家规模上被放大后，就有可能形成封闭的经济种姓制度，使得穷人很难改变他们的人生轨迹。当我们伸出援手与不同经济地位的人建立联系时，它有可能改变我们的生活、他们的生活以及遥远未来陌生人的生活。
It's natural to want to spend time with people who I like us. It doesn't make you a bad person to join a book club or a bird watching group and find others who share the same interests, backgrounds and temperaments. But this very human impulse, magnified on the scale of a nation, has the propensity to create sealed economic caste systems, where it becomes very hard for people who are poor to change the trajectory of their lives. When we reach out to form connections with people in different economic stations, it has the potential to transform our lives, their lives, and the lives of strangers in the
Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括Bridget McCarthy、Annie Murphy-Paul、Kristen Wong、Laura Correll、Ryan Katz、Autumn Barnes和Andrew Chadwick。Tara Boyle是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。今天的《Anson Quiro》，我们为您带来一个来自我们姐妹节目《My Anson Quiro》的故事。今天的故事来自Senna Karumi。几年前，Senna住在法国，攻读博士学位。一个寒冷的冬日周末，她和朋友们休息了一天，在
far future. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Correll, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. For today's Anson Quiro, we're bringing you a story from our sister show, My Anson Quiro. Today's story comes from Senna Karumi. Some years ago Senna was living in France, working on a PhD. One cold winter weekend, she and her friends took a break and spent the day
巴黎迪士尼乐园度过。他们待到尽可能晚，直到终于到了赶最后一班电车回家的时候。Senna的朋友们一个接一个地在各自的站点下车，直到只剩下她一个人。我注意到电车非常空，里面只有两个人，两个家伙，他们是朋友，我戴着头巾，我走的时候真的很显眼，我确实很显眼。其中一个人在电车的前面。另一个人坐在Senna后面几排。她觉得他们都没有太注意她或她的头巾，所以
at Disneyland Paris. This state as long as they could until it was finally time to catch the last tram home. One by one, all of Senna's friends got off at their stops until she was the only one left. And I noticed that the tram was super empty like there was just two people in there, two guys, both of them friends, and I wear the hijabs, I really stand out when I go, I do stand out. One of the men was in the front of the tram. The other set a few rows behind Senna. She didn't feel like either of them were paying her or her headscarf much attention, so
她戴上耳机，看向窗外。有些东西，也许是切换，比如音乐之间的时间或其他什么，当你有一点小小的沉默时，我听到了一些声音，转过头，看到这个家伙非常激动。他挥舞着双手，咒骂着，指着我的方向，我不确定他是在对我还是对另一个人，因为我没有做任何可能触发他那样做的事情。
she put on her headphones and looked out the window. Something, maybe the switch, like the time between music or something like this, when you have the small silence, I heard something and it turned and I saw this guy just being very agitated. He was waving his hands and swearing and just pointing in my direction and I wasn't sure if it was me or the other guy because I didn't do anything that may trigger him to do that.
所以我以为他可能是在和身后的那个人说话。我摘下耳机，那时我听到了他说的所有那些非常恶毒的话，说我们戴着头巾，说我们让欧洲变得不文明，说我们是欧洲和法国一切错误的原因。那一刻我想，是的，这是针对我的，这绝对是针对我的。我不害怕，我只是麻木和震惊，我不明白为什么会发生这种情况。我甚至没想过我会处于危险之中，但就像是，为什么？
So I assumed that he was probably talking to the guy behind me. I took my head's phone off, and that when I heard all those very harmful words that he was saying, that we took the jobs, that we are making Europe and civilized, that we are everything that is wrong with Europe and France. At that moment I was like, yes, this is about me, this is differently about me. I wasn't scared, I was just numb and shocked, I didn't understand why is this happening. I didn't even cross my mind that I would be in danger, but it was like, why?
为什么？为什么？我做了什么？为什么？就在Senna开始站起来时，那个一直坐在她身后的男人冲到电车前面，挡在了她和那个愤怒的男人之间。几秒钟后，他站在我面前，不停地推电车的门。他一直在说，你不准碰她，你不准对她说那些话，她只是个学生。欧洲的一切错误都是因为你。这句话我记得非常清楚。欧洲的一切错误都是像你这样的人，而不是她。
Why? Why? What did I do? Why? Just a senna began to stand, the man who had been sitting behind her rushed to the front of the tram and placed himself between her and the angry man. A few seconds he was up front of me and he kept on pushing the door of the tram. He kept on saying, you don't touch her, you don't say those words to her, she's just a student. Everything is wrong with Europe, it's you. At this phrase I remember it very clearly. Everything that is wrong with Europe is people like you, not her.
那个保护Senna的男人阻止了愤怒的男人靠近她。起初，他一直把他推向电车门，当司机停下电车时，这个家伙需要在下一站下车。电车一停，他就把那个人推下了电车，然后站在门口确保他无法再上来。他站在那里，没有和我说话，只是站在门口，就像在看着我。当你戴着面纱时，这种情况经常发生，尤其是在法国。当他们看到你戴着面纱时，他们真的不知道如何与你互动。
The man defending Senna kept the angry man from getting close to her. At the beginning he kept pushing him toward the tramway door and at the driver stopped the tram, this guy needs to get off the next station. Once the tram stopped, he pushed the man off the tram and then stood by the doors to make sure he couldn't get back on. He stayed there, didn't talk to me, stayed by the door, just like watching me. This happens a lot when you are veiled and especially in France. When they see you as veiled, they really don't know how to interact with you.
他们不知道你的界限在哪里。有些人认为这就是他没有过来和我说话的原因。虽然这根本不会有问题，我可能还会欢迎它，但我很确定这就是原因。所以Senna当时太震惊了，什么也说不出来。她和那个男人在电车上沉默地站着，直到她的站点到了。当她下车时，那个男人跟着她，确保她安全进入了她的楼里。Senna仍然处于极度震惊中，无法回头说再见。这是我一生中第一次遇到这样的事情。我当然听过故事，
They don't know what are your boundaries. Some assuming that's why he didn't come and talk to me. Although it would have not been a problem at all, I probably would have welcomed it, but I'm pretty sure that that's the reason. So now it was too shocked to say anything either. She and the man stood in silence on the tram until her stop came. When she got out, the man followed and made sure that she got into her building safely. Senna was still in too much shock to turn around and say goodbye. It was the very first time that I encountered something like it in my entire life. I heard stories, of course I did,
我知道这会发生，但我从没想过会发生在我身上。在那一刻，即使是那个好人所做的事情，也没有被我意识到，我仍然太专注于那个坏人说的话。他为什么要攻击我？我做了什么？然后不知何故，我想，哦，等等，
I knew that it happens, but I never assumed that it would happen to me. And at the moment, even what the nice guy did, it didn't register, I was still so focused on what the bad guy said. Why was he attacking me? What did I do? And then somehow I was like, oh, but wait,
我并不是一个人。还有另一个人，他知道我没有做错任何事，我不应该受到仇恨和暴力。他实际上保护了我。然后我说，等等，他没有理由保护我。他没有分享相同的信仰和文化。然而他就在那里。他实际上把自己
I wasn't alone in this. There was another guy who kind of knew that I didn't do anything wrong, that I didn't deserve the hatred and the violence. And he actually defended me. And then I said, wait, he had no reason to defend me. He wasn't sharing the same beliefs and the same culture. And yet he was there. He actually put himself
置于危险之中。他可能会受伤。他可能会惹上大麻烦。但他没有考虑这些。从那天起，每当Sana经历伊斯兰恐惧症时，她都会想起那个保护她的男人。他的善良和勇气给了她留在法国的力量。我不记得那天我被一个陌生人攻击，我记得那天我被一个陌生人拯救。这产生了所有的不同，所有的不同。我真的非常非常感谢那个家伙。
in danger by doing that. He could have gotten hurt. He could have gotten in so much trouble. And he didn't think about that. Every time Sana experienced Islamophobia after that day, she remembered the man who defended her. His kindness and courage gave her the strength to remain in France. I don't remember it as the day where I was attacked by a stranger, I remembered as the day where I was saved by a stranger. And that made all the difference, all the difference. And I'm really, really grateful to that guy for this.
Lysna Senna Karumi。事件发生几年后，Senna完成了博士学位，回到了她的祖国摩洛哥。当我们与她交谈时，她正在担任国际管理顾问。如果您想帮助我们制作更多这样的故事，请立即行动。访问support.hiddenbrain.org，加入数百名已经注册提供帮助的Hidden Brain听众。再次强调，是support.hiddenbrain.org。
Lysna Senna Karumi. Some years after the incident, Senna finished her PhD and moved back to her home country of Morocco. When we spoke to her, she was working as an international management consultant. If you would like to help us build more stories like this, please act now. Visit support.hiddenbrain.org and join the hundreds of other hidden brain listeners who have signed up to help. Again, that support.hiddenbrain.org.
我是Shankar Vedantum。很快再见。目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
I'm Shankar Vedantum. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。再见。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。